TO GET THIS PARTY STARTED. ONE
OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS HEARING
TO CONSIDER TO YOUR BILLS. WERE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AT
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A
LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH
AND PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING
IN PERSON WE ARE REQUIRING THAT
MASKS TO BE WORN IN FISCAL
DISENTANGLING TAMED BY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING
HERE IN THIS ROOM. WILL ALSO BE
USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL
MCCOLLUM NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AGAIN
IT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE OR TWO.
AGAIN THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS WELL AS
ON THE TELEVISION. IF YOU WERE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON HIS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN KEY- BASED ON WHETHER
YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A BILL. WE
WILL BE LIMITING THE TESTIMONY
TO TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES. PER
BILL PER SIDE. IN TWO MINUTES
PER WITNESS. ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AND THEN STATE
THEIR NAME AND ORGANIZATION IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION FOR A
MAXIMUM OF THIRTY MINUTES OF
PUBLIC TESTIMONY. WE I ALSO WANT
TO NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. WE HAVE
FOUR ITEMS SICK DAY INCLUDING
ONE BILL ON CONSENT- AND IS JUST
AN UPDATE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
SIXTY FOUR HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR- WITH THAT BEING SAID
LET'S QUICKLY- TAKE A ROLE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. BERMAN HERE.
FROM HERE FOR YOUR BLOOM YEAH
BONTA. WHEN CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES
FONG. GIPSON GRAYSON THERE ARE
ONE ME YEAH MCCARTY MEDINA.
MULLIN THANK WEBER. GREAT WE
HAVE A QUORUM- AND SO LET'S GET
STARTED WITH TODAY'S AGENDA THE
FIRST BILL ON THE AGENDA IS A B.
TWO NINE FOUR BY SON OVER
SANTIAGO WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
HEY MISTER. POSTED THE SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HAVING
HEARD THAT I WILL MAKE MY
COMMENTS MUCH BRIEFER OTHER TO
SAY THIS WILL GIVE THE CONSUMER
A PLACE TO- A PLACE TO GO TO
MAKE COMPLAINTS ABOUT
EXTRAORDINARY FEES FOR TOOK A
STORE NEAR FEES WHEN THEIR CAR
HAS BEEN TOWED AND IT DOES IT.
IT DOES A PRIMARILY BY SETTING
UP- THE VEHICLE TOWING STORAGE
BOARD- IT ALSO WOULD REQUIRE ALL
BUSINESSES ATTAIN- VEHICLE
STORAGE AND- A B. X. VEHICLE TOW
AND STORAGE PERMITS- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I. WHAT
WE HAVE TO WITNESSES WHICH I
WILL ALSO ASK TO BE BRIEF
BECAUSE IT. FEELS THAT THAT
THAT- THE COMMITTEE IS
ENCOURAGING- OTHERWISE I WILL
GIVE YOU MY TWO THREE PAGE- I
YOU KNOW- DIVE INTO THE DETAILS
A LITTLE BIT FOR US OKAY YEAH.
YEAH NO PROBLEM. AND I
UNDERSTAND ALSO THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAD SOME CONCERNS WITH
WILL BE ADDRESSING ALSO. AND IN
THE NEXT COMMITTEE SO WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. AB TWO NINETY
FOUR WOULD PROVIDE A CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS AFFAIRS SIMPLE PROCESS
TO CHALLENGE EXCESSIVE TOWING.
FEES THAT EXCEED- IN SOME OF
THEM DO EXCEED A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A DAY WE'VE SEEN THAT-
AND RIGHT NOW BECAUSE IT HAS
NOWHERE TO GO WILL BE ABLE TO. I
CHALLENGE THOSE FEES AND WHAT
WHAT ESTABLISHED. YOU HOPE
COMMAND THE BOARD. THE BOARD HAS
. THAT HAVE- FOLKS IN THE
INDUSTRY- A POST. I THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO TIENEN TO WHETHER
FEES- WORK STORE. OR NOT AT A
POP AND WOULD BE ABLE TO. THE
CONSUMER ABLE TO COLLECT
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE SOME TO BE
ABLE TO COLLECT. TO BE ABLE TO-
REALLY- CHALLENGE SOME OF THOSE
FEES AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HOPING TO DO BY THIS. AWESOME
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND WE
HAVE TO WOODS WHICH WILL ALSO
HAVE TO BE THINKING. GREAT THANK
YOU- SUMMER SANTIAGO INTO
ANDERSON THE WITNESSES ARE KIRK. BLACKBURN AND SEREN TAYLOR.
REMOTELY CORRECT GREAT- SO- AT&T
SECRETARY OR WHOEVER WE'VE GOT
GOING ON. IF YOU CAN IDENTIFY
KIRK AND SEREN TO TESTIFY THAT
BE GREAT. HI GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS OF THE COURT BLACKBURN
OF ELIGIBLES NABS THE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA TOW
TRUCK ASSOCIATION A SPONSORED IN
A REPORT- INITIALLY JUST WANNA
THANK A MEMBER SANTIAGO OFFERING
THIS IMPORTANT BILL AS WELL AS
YOUR PERMANENT STAFF. PROVIDING
US WITH EXCELLENT FEEDBACK
ANNOUNCEMENTS. I THINK YOU D. A.
SEVEN UP TO SPONSOR A BETWEEN A
QUARTER TRAFFIC OVERSIGHT IN
CALIFORNIA THE LACK OF A STATE
WIDE ENTITY REGULATING THE
TOWING INDUSTRY. WELL HERE ARE
NUMBER CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
PROVIDED UNDER CURRENT LAW
THERE'S A LACK OF ENFORCEMENT TO
PREVENT BAD ACTORS IN INDUSTRY
FROM CIRCUMVENT A LOT. FURTHER
VEHICLE OWNERS OFTENTIMES LEFT
INFUSED AND WITHOUT USING
RECORDS OFFICIALLY THEY WERE
OVER. CHARGING THE VEHICLES TO-
AB T. NINE FOUR WITH. THIS
OVERSIGHT ENACTING A PERCENT ON
THE- TO SOME. IN THE- TONES PART
. EVERY BUSINESS OP A TOTAL ****
FOR THE STILL. OF TOKYO CAL BUT
YOU APPLY A VEHICLE CAL AND-
TERM FROM THE BOY. AND THE BOARD
WITHOUT THAT THE TO SUSPEND THE
PRIMARY STYLISH BUT LAW- AND THE
- OF A PAIN THE- THIS. WE NEED
COME IN THE HOUSE OF ETHNIC.
ORDER CALM BECAUSE INFORMATION.
AND AUTHORIZED. STORY H. ALL OF
WHICH BE POSTED THE BOARD'S WEB
. FIFTY GET. I YOUR SACRAMENTO.
FURTHER IN ORDER JUST OVER
BILLION THE BILL AND I OF THREE
. CONSUMER FROM JUST RESOLUTION
IN THE- WE'RE BACK INTO CAN SWIM
RECOVERED ANY FEES. AND
ATHLETICALLY THAT WERE IN A CAR
PAID ON TOP CLASS PENALTIES. THE
CONSUMERS PRISON TO BE RIGHT
WITHIN THE SYSTEM. AND THE
TELLING COMPANY AS A PARTNER. A
PROVEN FACT QUITE LEGAL. THIS
PROCESS WOULD ADD PETER THAT'S
LAWS THAT REQUIRE INCOME TO BUY
BY THEIR- APPROACH RATES BY.
WHICH WAS NOT. AND THAT'S A BILL
TO LEGAL TELL THE IN THE STATE.
OVERALL WE WILL THIS BILL THE
CRITICAL STEP TO CURBING ATTACK
. WHEN WITHIN THE INDUSTRY- SO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANNEX OF SERRA TAYLOR. IN BETTER
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM THE
ABUSES AND EXORBITANT CHARGES IN
THE TOWING AND AUTO REPAIR
INDUSTRIES. NOT SURPRISINGLY THE
TOTAL BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA IS
LARGELY UNREGULATED AND THERE'S
NO RELIABLE DATABASE OF TOTAL
VEHICLES OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA%
. THAT MAKES IT DIFFICULT TO
IDENTIFY BAD ACTORS AND TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS WHEN
APPROPRIATE SO WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND COMMEND THE
CALIFORNIA TOW TRUCK ASSOCIATION
FOR COMING FORWARD WITH A
PROPOSAL TO PUT SOME
ACCOUNTABILITY AROUND THE TOWING
INDUSTRY. TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMERS AND READ OUT THE BAD
APPLES. YEAH IN ADDITION TO
PROVIDING OVERSIGHT FOR TOWERS.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS OF THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE EXCESSIVE STORAGE
RATES CHARGED BY OUR REPAIR
DEALERS. WHILE MOST AUTO BODY
REPAIR DEALERS ARE RESPONSIBLE
WE'RE STILL SEEING TOO MANY THAT
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
CONSUMERS AND CHARGING EXCESSIVE
RAGE THAT COST INSURANCE POLICY
HOLDER YOU'RE JUST PLAIN
DOLLARS. AND PERPETUATE A CYCLE
OF POVERTY FOR THE LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS WHO CAN AFFORD TO
PAY STORAGE BILLS AND YOUR CAR'S
AND SOMETIMES THEIR LIVELIHOOD.
DOCTORS ARGUES THAT THE CURRENT
SYSTEM IS WORKING FINE TO
PROTECT CONSUMER. BUT OUR
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT'S NOT
THE CASE. WE FIND IT STILL
COMMON FOR AUTO REPAIR DEALERS
TO CHARGE STORAGE FEES ARE IN
EXCESS OF TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER DAY. AND SOMETIMES IN EXCESS
OF A THOUSAND DOLLARS PER DAY.
BY COMPARISON STORAGE RATE PAID
BY CHP AND HIGH COST CITIES LIKE
SAN FRANCISCO IS NINETY THREE
DOLLARS PER DAY. CURRENTLY
THERE'S NO REGULATOR THAT HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO DEFINE
REASONABLE STORAGE RATES. OR
REQUIRE AN UNSCRUPULOUS BUSINESS
TO CONSUMER PROCESSING CHARGES.
THE ONLY REMEDY FOR CONSUMER
MARKETS TO BRING A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE TOWING STORAGE
FACILITY FOR DAMAGES. THAT'S NOT
PRACTICAL FOR MOST PEOPLE. WHEN
CLOSING. AB TWO NINETY FOUR WILL
PROVIDE THE REGULATORY
ACCOUNTABILITY LACKING IN THE
TOWING INDUSTRY. AND ESTABLISH A
FAIR AND RESPONSIBLE STORAGE
WAIT BENCHMARK THAT IS BASED ON
REGIONAL H. NEGOTIATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN MY VOTE.
THANK YOU THINK THANKS SO MUCH I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TO- PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION JACK
MORE THAN OFF MALATI MILLOT AN
OFFICE USE ME. WE TESTIFYING VIA
TELEPHONE AND JOE COLLINS WHO I
BELIEVE IS TESTIFYING IN PERSON.
ONE WE GO FIRST- AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO JOE. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING- COMMITTEE- CARE.
PROJECT MODOC ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA AUTOBODY ASSOCIATION
THE AUTOMOTIVE SERVICE COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
AUTOMOTIVE BUSINESS COALITION
WERE OPPOSED UNLESS BILL
COMMENDED. THE BILL IS NOT
NECESSARY WITH REGARD TO
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR DEALER'S
AUTOMOTIVE WITH CAR DEALERS ON
THE BUSINESS OF REPAIRING CARS.
AND ARE AND ARE REGULATED BY THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR S.
B. A. R. YOU COULD IN ANY
STORAGE FEES THEY MAY CHARGE.
THE TOWING INDUSTRY IS NOT
REGULATED BY THE B. A. R. THE
TOWING INDUSTRY AND THE AUTO
REPAIR INDUSTRY A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES. THE BUREAU
OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR. RECEIVED
APPROXIMATELY FIFTEEN THOUSAND
CONSUMER COMPLAINT HERE HOW TO.
OKAY CONSUMER COMPLAINT ONLY.
ARE RELATED JUST. EVEN THOUGH
THE NUMBER IS VERY LOW B. A. R.
TREATS THE STORE COMPLAINTS
SERIOUSLY THE INVESTIGATED
MEDIATE AND HAVE TAKEN
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR DEALER'S
RELATED STORAGE IS USED. AB FOUR
SEVENTY ONE WHICH PASSED LAST
YEAR IT WAS A LOW BILL IT TOOK
EFFECT JANUARY FIRST OF THIS
YEAR. WHICH STRENGTHENS AND
PROVIDES ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY TO
BE A ARE OVER AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
SHOPS WITH REGARD STORAGE IN
FACT THEY ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
PROMULGATING STORAGE REGULATIONS
AND THEY JUST HELD A WORKSHOP IN
OCTOBER. THERE'S NO NEED TO
CREATE ANOTHER REGULATORY BOARD
TO AGREE AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
DEALER'S TO DEAL WITH ONLY SIXTY
STORAGE COMPLAINT. WE ARE
REQUESTING THE BILL BE AMENDED
TO EXCLUDE AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
DEALER'S THAT DO NOT HAVE TO-
TRUCKS AND INSTEAD. WORK WITH
THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
TO IMPROVE AND STRENGTHEN
STORAGE ISSUES THROUGH THE
PENDING REGULATORY PROCESS. WE
THINK THIS IS A MUCH BETTER
APPROACH ALSO THE BILL PROHIBITS
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR DEALER FROM
CHARGING FAIR IN MOVIES MORE
STORAGE RATE. LAW IF THAT IS
CONDITIONS FOR WEEDS MORE
STORAGE RATE THE LAW CREATED AT
YEARS AGO BY SOME SAKE. BILL A
TWENTY THREE TWO ALL THE STATE
CALL AND THIS. OF THIS BILL
NEGOTIATED THE STORAGE WAIT
DEFINITIONS THE STATE. LAW
PROVIDES THAT AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
DEALER'S MAY CHARGE REASONABLE
RATES WHICH ARE DETERMINED BY
COMPARING RATES TO OTHER SHOPS
IN THE LOCAL AREA. TOLD TRUCK.
THEIR THEIR RATES ARE DETERMINED
AND GOVERNED BY THEIR NEGOTIATED
CONTRACTS WITH C. H. P. AND
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT. THE DEATH
. AS INTENDED. QUENTEC CURRENT
LAW NOT A LIMIT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
LET'S GO TO JOE COLLINS AND THEN
AFTER JOE ALL DO THE ME TOOS
WHICH I SKIPPED EARLIER- SO
WE'LL GO BACK TO ME TO USE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. THANKS
JEFF. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
CHOKE FUNDS I REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION LICENSE
REPOSSESSIONS. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT FOUR THINGS. IT'S ABOUT
REGULATING TOW TRUCKS. IT'S
ABOUT REGULATING TELL VEHICLES.
IT'S ABOUT REGULATING STORAGE
TRUCK YOU STORAGE YARD. AND IT'S
ABOUT THE LIEN SALE PROCESS. ALL
OF THESE THE CALIFORNIA TOW
TRUCK ASSOCIATION WILL STAND TO
MAKE TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IF YOU ALLOW THIS BILL TO LEAVE
YOUR COMMITTEE. THEY WANT TO
REGULATE TE TOW TRUCK. YOU HAVE
TO GO BE CERTIFIED AS A TOWER IN
THE ONLY PERSON THAT CERTIFIES
IN THE STATE IS A CALIFORNIA TOW
TRUCK ASSOCIATION. THEY ALSO
CERTIFY THE AUTOMOBILE CLUB OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THEY RUN
THAT PROGRAM TO CERTIFY TRUCKS.
SO THEY GET THIS BILL PASSED.
THEY MAKE MONEY. BILLION CELL
PROCESS IF YOU LOOK AT THE CODE
THIS BILL IF THEY WROTE IT SAYS
THAT THEY GET TO. REGULATE THE
LIEN SALE PROCESS. WELL I'M SURE
THE DEPARTMENT OF AIRPORTS WOULD
WANT TO HEAR ABOUT THAT BECAUSE
THEY FILED LIENS. I'M SURE THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES WOULD WANT TO
HEAR IT THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
THEY SHOULD HEARD THIS BILL BUT
THE WAY THEY WROTE IT. YOU WOULD
THINK IT ONLY PERTAINS TO
TELLING BUT IT DOES NOT IT'S THE
ENTIRE LIEN SALE PROCESS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE BUREAU
OF SECURITY INVESTIGATOR
SERVICES REGULATES REPOSSESSION
AGENCY. WERE IN THE BOOK. WE'RE
REGULATED BY THE DCA WE HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES ACT WE DON'T EVEN
BELONG IN THIS ACT BECAUSE WE
DON'T CHARGE TOWING AND STORAGE
WE REPOSSESS THE CAR GOES
THROUGH A LOT THE FINANCE
COMPANY DETERMINES WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO WITH IT WHERE IT GOES
AND THAT'S ALL MANDATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMERCIAL CODE.
THERE'S NOTHING WE DO THAT WOULD
PUT US HERE AND THERE'S NOTHING
THAT THE AUTO THIS MEMBERS DO
THAT WOULD PUT THEM IN THIS
EITHER BUT THEY DREADED TELL
VEHICLE AND THEY JUST- JUNK CARS
A PART AMOUNT MAKE SURE THEY
SHOULDN'T BE IN THIS BILL. THIS
BILL IS A WOLF IN SHEEP'S
CLOTHING AND THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS ARE GONNA GET HURT I
PASSED MANY BILLS FOR THIS
COMMITTEE AND I GOTTA TELL YEAH.
IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT BEING FOR AND
RE. YOUR THE GATEKEEPERS YOU'RE
THE ONES THAT HAVE THE MISSION
STATEMENT THAT SAYS WE REPRESENT
THE CONSUMER. THERE HAS TO BE
FAIR IT HAS TO BE REASONABLE.
EVERY RATE THEY HAVE IN THEIR
ACT. CAN BE VOTE INVALIDATED BY
SAYING YES THEY DIDN'T CHARGE
THE RIGHT RATE BUT WE BELIEVE
IT'S REASONABLE. AND THAT'S IT
THAT'S A WRAP YOU DON'T GET
ANYTHING. AND IF YOU DO DISPUTED
IF YOUR AUTO INSURANCE COMPANY.
OR A REPOSSESSION YOU DISPUTED.
AND THEY SAY YES YOU'RE CORRECT.
YOU DON'T EVEN GET YOUR MONEY
BACK IF YOU PAID FOR THE CAR HE
JUST SAID IT TO THE REGISTERED
OWNER. YOU DON'T GET YOUR MONEY
BACK. THANK YOU AVERAGE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- SO LET'S GO TO ME
TO USE- FIRST- AND ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO. ADD ON IN SUPPORT AND
THEN WE'LL GO TO ANYBODY WANT TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION. ANYBODY IN
THE HEARING ROOM ONCE AT ON IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NINE OR DOING
PUBLIC TESTIMONY SESSIONS- NOT
SO MUCH ALL RIGHT ANYBODY ON THE
TELEPHONE WHO WANTS THAT ON- IN
SUPPORT OF. AB TWO NINETY FOUR.
HMNY SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ON TO NINETY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. JUST ONE MORE WELL
WE HAVE ONE CUTE. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AT ANY RATE- HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE ASSOCIATION
ASKING FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
CHECK FOR I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH DOZENS
FROM THE GENTLEMAN FROM THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME GREAT IS THERE
ANYBODY. IN THE HEARING ROOM IN
OPPOSITION WHO WANTS AT ON- IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANYBODY ON THE
TELEPHONE WHO WANTS TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND JUST WHEN WE DO
HAVE ONE QUEUING UP.
OKAY AND.
THE LABEL GOT A LATE ONE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU. AB APOLOGIZE THEY'VE WANTED
TO Q. AND DROPPED. NORRIS. AND
NOBODY ELSE LINKED. I DON'T
THINK YOU ARE I WILL BRING BACK
TO COLLEAGUES- FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR THE AUTHOR FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- YES MISSOURI. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY BUT- I
WOULD LIKE TO SEE YOU CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH- OPPOSITION THERE
SEEM TO BE SOME. STRUCTURAL
ISSUES IN THE BILL AND SOME
POLICY ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT
UP IN. IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
I THINK FOR ALL OF US WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN DO WITH
THE PREDATORY- THE TOWING
PRACTICES BUT WITHOUT UNDULY.
BURDENING TAXPAYERS WE SHOULD I
THINK YOU HAVE TO. THE MISSOURI
ONE ANY ADDITION QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. YES BECAUSE RESIDENTS THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN I ALSO SURE CINEMAS
WITH MY COLLEAGUE JUST ASKING
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK I ALL
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH WITH THIS
BILL AND THE PAST COUPLE REAL- A
PASSEL WHILE I THINK IT'S WORTHY
FOR YOU TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION BUT TO DEFINITELY
SEE YOU- WORK WITH OPPOSITION
AND TRY TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUES
AT HAND. WITH AN ADDRESS FOR
YEARS SO WE WILL CONTINUE I
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU MISTER GRAYSON ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- SO. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. LAST WHEN I VOTE MISTER
CHAIRMAN BRUCE THANK YOU. WE
WANT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRING THE BILL FORD AND YEAH I
THINK EVERYBODY ON THE COMMITTEE
AGREES THAT THAT THERE'S A
PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED- BUT IT'S- A
COMPLICATED. YEAH BUT ADDRESSING
THAT PROBLEM IS IT IS
COMPLICATED AND SETTING UP A NEW
BOARD- IS INCREDIBLY COMPLICATED
AND YEAH I WANT TO JUST QUICKLY
THANK COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR A-
DAY I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY MY
COLLEAGUES REALIZE A TWENTY
EIGHT PAGE. ANALYSIS OF THIS
BILL. WHICH YOU KNOW I'VE NEVER
SEEN A TWENTY EIGHT PAGE
ANALYSIS FOR A BILL BEFORE-
WHICH WAS INCREDIBLY EDUCATIONAL
AND INFORMATIONAL. BUT ALSO
IDENTIFIES A WHOLE LIST OF. I
REQUEST. I'M M. WHICH YOU KNOW
THEY THEY REALLY LAY OUT
QUESTION STARTING PAGE IN LIKE
TWENTY SIX OF THE IN OUR- IN
THERE IS A THE BOTTOM PAGE
TWENTY FIVE AND THERE'S A LOT
THERE'S A LOT THERE- AND I KNOW
THAT I'M A NEW CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE AYE I JUST ENTER IT
NOT LONG AGO I KNOW THERE'S SOME
STAFF CHANGES ON ON WHO WAS
POINT PERSON FOR THIS BILL- IN
ORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES- I'D WANT
A LOT MORE ANSWERS TO THESE
QUESTIONS BEFORE I'D BE
COMFORTABLE SUPPORT THE BILL IN.
COMMITTEE GIVE IT. OUR
CIRCUMSTANCE OF TAKING OVER THE
CAN PRETTY LATE- I'M OKAY WITH
WITH YOU KNOW RECOMMENDING
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL- TO PASS
OUT OF COMMITTEE TODAY BUT BUT
WITH AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT WELL
WHAT YOU PROVIDED I APPRECIATE-
MISTER SUNDAY AS A MEMBER
SANTIAGO IS THAT. YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO WORK TO ANSWER
ALL THOSE QUESTIONS- BEFORE THE
END OF THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
BECAUSE THERE'S- YOU KNOW SHOULD
BE A BORDER BUREAU ONE OF THE UP
FRONT COSTS THERE'S- DISPUTE AS
TO HOW MANY- DIFFERENT TOW TRUCK
COMPANIES THERE ARE. IN
CALIFORNIA BROAD DISPUTE BETWEEN
THE CALIFORNIA. RESEARCH BUREAU
AND THEN THE NUMBER- PROVIDED BY
THE SPONSORS OF THE COMMITTEE. A
LOT OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
BURNHAM BURDEN OF PROOF IN TERMS
OF ART WHERE THERE ARE
DEFINITIONS FOR UNREASONABLY
EXCESSIVE TIMER. VISUALLY
REBUTTED ARE PERTINENT DETAILS-
25% OF THE PENALTIES BEING KEPT
BY THE BOARD IS UNIQUE WE DON'T
HAVE THAT STRUCTURE IN ANY OTHER
BOARDS IN CALIFORNIA- SHOULD
THERE BE AN APPEAL PROCESS
SHOULD THEIR PURIFICATION
PROCESS. THESE ARE ALL- YOU
KNOW. NOT DISPUTING THE NEED FOR
TO IT TO DO MORE TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS BUT REALLY QUESTIONING
THE SPECIFICS. FOR HOW WE- I'M
AN N. AS AS YOU KNOW. OF ANYONE
THE DEVIL IN THE DETAILS- SO.
I'M COMFORTABLE- THE VERY. SOME
FOR THE BILL TODAY BUT BUT YOU
KNOW- IT AND GET A APPRECIATE.
YOU KNOW YOUR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
WORK OUT ALL THE DIRTY DETAILS
OF THIS PROPOSAL- BEFORE THE
BILL COMES BACK ON CONCURRENCE-
AND SO WITH THAT- AND YOU KNOW
DOESN'T WANT TO CREATE YOU TO
WORK WITH. THE OPPOSITION AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS I KNOW YOU
HAVE BEEN IN AND I KNOW YOU KNOW
YOU TO THERE BEEN SOME GOOD
CONVERSATION JUST IN THE PAST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS. I'M SO YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THAT
TO CONTINUE- BUT WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO- RECOMMEND. SUPPORT FOR
THE- PLEASE CALL THE VOTE. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI BERMAN
HI FLORA FLORA I BLOOM BLOOM HI
BONTA BONTA AYE WHEN NOT VOTING
CUNNINGHAM. DAVIES DAVIES HI
FONG- FONG HI GIPSON GIPSON
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE IRWIN- WHEN
I WE AYE MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA
NOT VOTING MULLIN. MULLIN AREN'T
TEN WEBER HOWEVER I. THAT BILL-
HAS TWELVE AYE VOTES SO IT'S OUT
WILL CONTINUE TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- THANK
MRS SANTIAGO THANK YOU. SO WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT BILL. ON THE
AGENDA IS THAT THIS ONE. YEAH
WHICH IS AB SIX SEVENTY SIX- BY
SOMEONE NUMBER HOLDEN BUT BY
PRESENTED BY THE ESTEEMED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM. IT IS AN
HONOR AND A PRIVILEGE TO HAVE
YOU HERE TODAY SIR. AND LIKEWISE
. THE AMERICAN GRADUATING. SHARE
MEMBERS- I THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB SIX
SEVENTY SIX TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN THAT WHEN
THAT TERRIBLE PROBST ASKS I'M
INCLINED TO SAY YES SMART MAN
THE MOMENT THE WHOLE TAKE A
NUMBER OF STEPS TO RECTIFY THE
UNBALANCED RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
FRANCHISEE AND FRANCHISOR YOURS
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN AUTHORED AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE WHICH MADE
CALIFORNIA THE STANDARD BEARER
OF FAIRNESS FOR THE FRANCHISE OR
FRANCHISEE RELATIONSHIP. WELL AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE IMPROVE THESE
RELATIONSHIPS THERE IS STILL
MORE WORK TO DO TO BRING
FAIRNESS TO THE SYSTEM WHICH IS
WHY AB SIX SEVENTY SIX AS
NECESSARY. THE BILL DOES
MULTIPLE THINGS TO RESOLVE
ISSUES IT EXPLICITLY PROHIBITS
FRANCHISE SOURCE FROM
INFLUENCING WHERE FRANCHISEE CAN
PURCHASE A FRANCHISE BASED ON A
PROTECTED CLASS SUCH AS RACE.
RECENT REPORTS ON LAWSUITS
AGAINST MCDONALD'S BY AFRICAN
AMERICAN FRANCHISEES DETAIL THIS
ONGOING ISSUE. SOME FRANCHISORS
HAVE USED THE PANDEMIC AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CHANGE THEIR
LIABILITY THE TRANSFER BURDEN ON
TO FRANCHISEES IN EXCHANGE FOR
FINANCIAL HELP. THE BILL
PROHIBITS THAT. CURRENTLY
FRANCHISE DOORS CAN UNILATERALLY
DETERMINE THE AMOUNT THAT
FRANCHISEES ARE WHEN AN
AGREEMENT IS BEING TERMINATED OR
NOT RENEWED. THIS BILL CREATES A
MORE FAIR PROCESS WHERE BOTH
PARTIES HAVE A SAY. A TRANSFER
BY OUR OF A FRANCHISE THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED BEFORE TWENTY
SIXTEEN WILL NOT RECEIVE THE
PROTECTIONS ESTABLISHED BY AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE SIGNING A NEW FRANCHISE
CONTRACT AFTER THE LAW'S
ENACTMENT AND THIS BILL ENABLES
THAT. IT WILL ALSO INCLUDE
ADEQUATE DISCLOSURES AND ENSURE
THAT ALL FRANCHISE. FRANCHISORS
AND FRANCHISEES IN CALIFORNIA
ARE COVERED BY THE LAW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS ON
THIS BILL AS IT MOVES FORWARD
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE KEITH MILLER WHO
REPRESENTS THE FRANCHISEES IS
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
SIX SEVENTY SIX AND- THANKFULLY.
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD- SIMILAR YES
CHAIR BERMAN VICE CHAIR FLOOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY OF
COURSE I THANK- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN FOR AGAIN TAKING THE LEAD
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLOOM FOR STEPPING IN TODAY MY
NAME IS KEITH MILLER I AM HERE
TO SUPPORT AB SIX SEVEN SIX ON
BEHALF OF ITS TO SPONSOR. I FOR
MY OWN CONSULTING COMPANY IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FRANCHISEE
ADVOCACY CONSULTING. TO BETTER
ASSESS FRANCHISEES AND
CONCENTRATE ON LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT THE TRUE INVESTORS IN
THE INDUSTRY. ALSO SERVED AS THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND
ENGAGEMENT FOR THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF FRANCHISEES AND
DEALERS. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
I'VE BEEN A SUBWAY FRANCHISEE IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT. CURRENTLY WITH THREE
LOCATIONS IN GRASS VALLEY IN
AUBURN. SO YES I HAVE SKIN IN
THE GAME SO TO SPEAK. THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL WITH A
SIMPLE TO BUILD ON AND BETTER
CLARIFY WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE
PAST TO PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY. AND ULTIMATELY
PROTECT THE FRANCHISEE INVESTOR
IN CALIFORNIA. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA LAW CAN'T BE
WAIVED ON FRANCHISE IS LOCATED
IN THE STATE. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT PROSPECTIVE FRANCHISEES
BUYING INTO AN EXISTING.
FRANCHISE UNDERSTAND THE
APPROVAL REQUIREMENTS AND THE
FRANCHISE OR FOLLOWS THOSE
STANDARDS. WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT FRANCHISEES ARE TREATED
EQUALLY WITH RESPECT TO APPROVAL
OR FINANCIAL. NO MATTER WHAT
THEIR CHARACTERISTICS ARE OR THE
COMPOSITION OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD
YES. WE NEED TO ENSURE FRANCHISE
ALL HOURS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR VIOLATIONS OF STATE
FRANCHISE LAWS IF ANY OFFICER
AGENT OR EMPLOYEE VIOLATES THE
STATUTES AND WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT DISCLAIMERS ARE NOT USED TO
HIDE VIOLATIONS OF THE FRANCHISE
INVESTMENT LAW. THESE ARE THE
PRIMARY GOALS OF AB SIX SEVEN
SIX AS MENTIONED WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS WE DID TALK I DID
TALK TO THEIR REPRESENTATIVE ON
FRIDAY AND I KNOW THE ONE
CONCERN WE HAVE LANGUAGE THAT WE
CAN CLARIFY THEIR CONCERN. I
LOOK FOR CONTINUING THIS
DISCUSSION AND ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY THANK YOU. GET THIS
PROCESS RIGHT. THE LAST BILL
ANYBODY ELSE WANTS TO ADD ON- IN
SUPPORT OF THE- SIX SEVENTY SIX-
ANYBODY IN. TODAY THE NINE
ANYBODY CALLING IN- TO TESTIFY
AS A MEDIUM OF SUPPORT OF.
MISTER OPERATORS REALLY THEIR
RELUCTANCE BY THE FOR YOU THAT
YOU SEE SOME OF THESE. I OKAY M.
I. MICROPHONES ON THAT DOESN'T
HELP US SO LET'S LET'S GO TO THE
HEARING ROOM ANYBODY IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WANTS TO ADD ON
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX SEVENTY SIX
. SEEING NONE LET'S GO TO THE
REMOTE TECH- THE- THE CALLING
TESTIMONY MISTER OPERATORS
ANYBODY CALLING IN. WHO WANTS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX
SEVENTY SIX THIS IS A ADD ON- TO
THE BILL. AND IF WE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SIX
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND JUST
MORE SOMEBODY'S QUEUED UP AND
THEN NEVER GO JUST MOM ALL
GATHERED IN ONE.
GO AT LINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS KATIE
VOEPEL. I OWN AND OPERATE
MULTIPLE TIMES ALREADY GUYS I
DIDN'T ACTUALLY GALLERY AREA. I
APOLOGIZE I'M GETTING LOT OF
FEEDBACK AYE YOU ABLE TO GET
OKAY YEAH WE CAN HEAR YOU THIS
IS THE OPPORTUNITY JUST TO
PROVIDE YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH IF ANY
AND WHETHER OR NOT YOU SUPPORT.
OR OPPOSE THE BILL. THANK YOU MY
NAME IS. PEOPLE WELL I WOULD BE
A WHOLE LOT OF THE ASIAN
AMERICAN HOTEL OWNERS
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE THE WORLD'S
LARGEST HELLO DEBATE. NUMBER
SEVENTY THREE OF THE CLOCK.
COUNTRY AND I'M IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE. AND WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME FOR SUPPORT. GREAT SO
LET'S MOVE ON TO- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE
JEFF HANDS COME FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL FRANCHISE
ASSOCIATION. WHO WE TESTIFYING
BY PHONE- IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SIX SEVENTY SIX- JEFF. BY IF
YOU'RE THERE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOU
GOT TWO MINUTES. SEVEN BERMAN
VICE CHANCELLOR MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA PER SHIFT UP AND IT JUST
HAPPENED WITH INTERNATIONAL
FRANCHISE ASSOCIATION- AND
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN- AND MR MILLER'S
OFFER TO CONTINUE WORKING ON
THIS BILL AS WE WILL- CONTINUE
TO ENGAGE WITH THAT BUT- IN ITS
CURRENT FORM- WEEK WE HAVE TO
OPPOSE IT. AT AT THE STANDS
RIGHT NOW- AND YOU KNOW
CURRENTLY CRAFTING WE FIND
LEGISLATION TO BE UNCLEAR
TREATING MORE QUESTIONS THAN IT.
PROVIDES ANSWERS AND POTENTIALLY
JUST TELEVISED BIG BEHAVIOR THAT
CAN ACTUALLY BENEFIT FRANCHISEES
AND ULTIMATELY WOULD LEAD TO AN
INCREASED LITIGATION BETWEEN
FRANCHISORS AND FRANCHISEES
OFTENTIMES OF NOT ACTUALLY
BENEFIT- BRANCH THE- WE ALSO.
SEEKING TO SOLVE A PROBLEM THAT
HAS NOT YET BEEN CLEARLY
IDENTIFIED- AND ATTEMPTS TO
AMEND LANGUAGE THAT WAS
PAINSTAKINGLY NEGOTIATED CRAFTED
AND AGREED UPON. BY ALL THE
PARTIES JUST A HANDFUL YEARS AGO
AS IT MENTIONED- EARLIER WHEN
THE FAMILY MEMBER HOLDEN.
PASSAGE OF ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
TWENTY FIVE BACK IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. SO WILLIAM WE SUBMITTED
WRITTEN TESTIMONY THAT OUTLINES
A NUMBER OF MARKETS ARE THE MORE
DETAILS SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
LIKE IF THAT CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE SPONSOR AND- COMPONENTS
LEGISLATION THAT. HOPE WE ARE
NOT MANY DIFFERENCES BUT YOU
KNOW OVERALL I GUESS THAT IN
INCREASING LITIGATION-
POTENTIALLY NEGATIVE IMPACT THE
FRANCHISEES MORE SO THAN
FRANCHISED STORES- THERE ALSO A
NUMBER OF PARTS OF THE BILL THAT
WE FIND- UNCLEAR AND VAGUE AT
THIS POINT- NOT. NOT NOT
OFFERING CLARITY ABOUT WHAT IT
IS IT'S ACTUALLY INTENDED TO
COVER- I. ALSO IN A DECADES- JR
A NUMBER. JURISDICTIONAL
EXPANSION OF THE I OVER. FOR
DOORS FRANCHISEES LOCATED
EXCLUSIVE OUTSIDE OF.
NEGOTIATING INVENT OF THE GROUP
EXTRA. AT THE A CAT CAL. TO GO
THROUGH- CALIFORNIA FROM. WHICH
IS NOT NOT ANY ONE- THERE'S ALSO
. NINE NINE AT APPEARS THE KERR
DRAFTED TO APPLY ANY NEW
FRANCHISE THEY'LL EVEN IF IT
TURNS OUT NOT TO BE A BILL AFTER
ALL WHICH IS AGAIN. ANOTHER
UNPRECEDENTED EXPANSION YEAH
FILE OF NO FRANCHISE LAW FEDERAL
OR STATE. HAS EVER REGULATED
ACROSS THAT. I WAS A FRANCHISE
OR GRANT ANY FRANCHISE- WITHOUT
GOING INTO TOO MUCH MORE DETAIL
I REALIZED MY TIME IS LIMITED.
SO I GUESS THAT WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN. MR MILLER OTHER
PROPONENTS BUT YOU HAVE TO
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION AT THE
BILL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU JEFFREY SAID THAT.
LET'S GO TO ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WANT TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL ANYBODY
IN THE HEARING ROOM WANT TO ADD
ON IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE
LET'S GO BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES- MISTER OPERATORS OR
ANYBODY WANTS TO ADD ON. A IN
OPPOSITION PROVIDING THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION PENNY. OPPOSITION.
TO THE BILL. WOULD YOU ONE UP
ONE NUMBER SIR EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD DAY. JOHN GORDON
RESIDENT OF- STANDI AGO ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT SEVENTY NINE. I'M A
BUSINESS OWNER AND RESTAURANT-
MANAGEMENT CONSULTANT IN SAN
DIEGO I WORK WITH THE FRANCHISE
IN VERY- EXTENSIVELY HI- BROGLIE
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL. SEVENTY
SIX. THIS IS BECAUSE THE IN THE
ASSEMBLY- BILL. SIX SEVENTY
THANK YOU THINK YOU ARE. THE AND
THEN THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT WE'RE
WE'RE TO THE POINT WHERE JUST
NAME. YOU KNOW ANY ORGANIZATION
AND SUPPORTER OPPOSITION SO WE
HAVE YOU DOWN IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES I
LOVE TO SAY IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- TWO EIGHTY SIX
SEVENTY SIX YOU JUST WANNA ADD
ON- NAME ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AND
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE CUED UP THIS
TIME GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THE COMMITTEE.
SCANNING THE DYESS SEEING NONE
SAYINGNONE- PRECIADO THAT BRING
IT BACK TO MR BLOOM THE- CLOSE
FOR MR OLDHAM. THANK YOU- AS I
SAID EARLIER MR HOLDEN HAS
ALREADY COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO.
ADDRESS SAID THAT THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED. AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU-
MISTER BLOOM FOR PRESENTING THIS
BILL ON BEHALF OF MR HOLDEN
TODAY- AND I AND I UNDERSTAND
THE AUTHOR HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
ADVOCACY ON THIS ISSUE. THE BOLD
BE HEARD IT NEXT IN JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE WHERE I'M SURE IT WILL
BE SUBJECT TO FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THE ISSUES THAT FALL. UNDER
THAT COMMITTEES JURISDICTION-
AND FOR PURPOSES OF TODAY'S
HEARING I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AS PRESENTED- PLEASE CALL
VOTE. THE MOTION IS DEEP THE-
COMMITTEE BERMAN HI BERMAN HI
FLORA. FLOOR HI BLOOM. BLOOM HI
BONTA. BONTA I WENT. WHEN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING DAVIES STEVIE'S AYE FONG
THAT FUN NOT VOTING GIPSON ALL
RIGHT GIPSON AYE GRAYSON- WENT.
BERMAN HIGHLY. WE ARE MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN. MULLIN
AYE TANK. WEBER HOWEVER I. GREAT
THAT BILL IS TWELVE VOTES- THAT
DOUBLES OUT BUT WE'LL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM THANK- SO
NOW WE'LL MOVE ON TO I BELIEVE
OUR LAST BILL THAT DAY. IS THAT
RIGHT- AND THEN WE'LL I THINK
IT'S I GALLAGHER- BUT LET'S MOVE
ON TO. AB ELEVEN TWENTY BY OUR
OWN COMMITTEE MEMBER. THAT'S ON
NUMBER ONE. MOVIOLA. GOT A
MOTION AS AND A COUPLE OF. SAID
ALL ALLOW TWENTY ALLOW HEALTH
FACILITIES AND HOSPITALS TO
AUTHORIZE THE USE OF NEW BLOOD
COLLECTION METHODS AND DEVICES
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE
THAT REQUIRES PHLEBOTOMIST TO
USE NEEDLES TO DRAW BLOOD EVEN
THOUGH NEW NEEDLELESS BLOOD
COLLECTION METHODS EXIST.
CALIFORNIA PATIENTS DESERVE
GREATER ACCESS TO NEW MEDICAL
PRACTICES THAT ARE SAFE AND MORE
COMFORTABLE ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT I'M SO PASSIONATE ABOUT
THIS IS THIS FALL MY DAUGHTER IN
LAW WAS IN THE HOSPITAL FOR
THREE WEEKS AND SHE HAD AN IV
LINE.ISA DAY. THE PHLEBOTOMIST
CAME IN TO DRAW BLOOD. AND TO-
OFTEN THEY COULDN'T FIND THE
VEINS THEY WERE GOING FROM ONE
ARM TO THE OTHER ARM. A DEVICE
LIKE THIS WOULD HAVE MADE HER
MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE. WE'VE HAD
DISCUSSIONS WITH- OF PEOPLE THAT
HAD CONCERNS OF OVER THE FALL
AND- IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE TOOK ONE OF-
CLARIFIES THAT'S THE HOSPITAL
DOES HAVE TO PROVIDE TRAINING
FOR THE PHLEBOTOMIST IT IS THAT
THEIR OPTION TO USE. THIS
TECHNIQUE. AND ALSO THERE WAS
SOME QUESTION ABOUT- THE NURSES-
BEING IN CHARGE OF THE
PERIPHERAL INTRAVENOUS CATHETER
AND WE HAVE VERY EXPLICITLY
STATED. THAT PHLEBOTOMIST ARE
NOT AUTHORIZED TO MANAGE STOP OR
RESTART A PATIENT'S ACTIVE
INTERVENE AS INFUSION. OR REMOVE
A PERIPHERAL INTRAVENOUS
CATHETER AND THE LANGUAGE GOES
EVEN FURTHER TO EMPHASIZE THAT A
PHYSICIAN AND SURGEON OR A
REGISTERED NURSE MAY RESTRICT OR
LIMIT PHLEBOTOMY PHLEBOTOMY
TECHNICIANS ABILITY TO COLLECT
BLOOD. FROM THESE DEVICES SO-
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE THAT TO
EXPERTS- IN SUPPORT DR P. TO.
AND DEVELOP A DEV GONE OF THE
LOT OF VASCULAR AND RYAN SPENCER
REPRESENTING- BECTON DICKINSON
AND COMPANY. SALAS THANK YOU AS
A MEMBER IRWIN- SO LET'S MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- DR DRIVE
GONE- AND RENTS A- WHO I THINK
SORRY ARE BOTH THAT'S FINE VIA
PHONE IS THAT RIGHT. ABOUT DR
LET'S GO TO THE- THAT I'M SORRY
DR A P. TO DEF CON IS ONE
PERSON. YES YES THE DOCTOR NEVER
GONE. IF YOU'RE AVAILABLE VIA
PHONE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND- START
YOUR TEST MANY OF TWO MINUTES.
CAN YOU ALL HEAR ME WITHOUT IT
UP ON I CAN'T WE CAN'T THANK YOU
. OKAY TERRIFIC THANK YOU- THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER EARLY MY
NAME IS DR PD DOT COM I AM THE
INVENTOR OF AN FDA CLEARED-
NEEDLE FREE BLOOD DRAW
TECHNOLOGY CALLED TIVO. PEOPLE
THE SINGLE USE DISPOSABLE DEVICE
TO TEMPORARILY CONNECT TO
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS PERIPHERAL
IV CATHETER TO ENABLE VIRTUALLY
PAINLESS AND RELIABLE BLOOD
DRIVE. THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA ARE
ADOPTING IV CATHETER BUT-
COLLECTION TECHNOLOGY WITH
PEOPLE TO IMPROVE THEIR PATIENTS
EXPERIENCE BY ELIMINATING
PAINFUL NEEDLES REDUCE THE RISK
OF NEEDLESTICK INJURIES FOR
THEIR STAFF MEMBERS. IMPROVE LAB
EFFICIENCY BY REDUCING THE
HOSPITAL'S REJECTED- BLOOD
SAMPLE RATE. THERE'S ROBUST
EVIDENCE SUPPORTING BLOOD DRAWS
FROM IV CATHETERS WITH PEOPLE
INCLUDING SIX PEER REVIEWED
JOURNAL PUBLICATIONS. OR QUICKLY
HIGHLIGHT THE MOST RECENTLY
PUBLISHED LARGEST REAL WORLD
STUDY EVER OF A NEEDLE FREE
BLOOD DRAW- TECHNOLOGY LIKE OURS
CONDUCTED BY INTERMOUNTAIN
HEALTHCARE. THERE THE LARGEST
HOSPITAL SYSTEM IN UTAH THAT
MAKES IT REALLY CLOSE CALIFORNIA
ACCOUNTING FOR MORE THAN 50% OF
ALL THE BEDS IN THE STATE. LIKE
MOST MOST LARGE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEMS THEY RELY ON THEIR
PHLEBOTOMIST TO COLLECT THE
MAJORITY OF THEIR INPATIENT
BLOOD SAMPLES. THE TRACTOR
PHLEBOTOMIST USING PEOPLE ACROSS
TWENTY TWO OF THE HOSPITAL OVER
A TWO YEAR PERIOD NOT COMPASS
TWO HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
PATIENT ADMISSIONS. WE BELIEVE
THIS IS THE LARGEST STUDY OF ITS
KIND FOR THE. VOTE EVER. R. D.
PUBLISHED I NEED POLLUTED A
FIFTY SIX FOR THE- IN BLOOD STEM
REJECT RATES. AND NINETEEN PER
LESS I THE ROOF. RATE TO
SUMMARIZE. THE BOTTOM INSTEAD
STATE FULLY AND OFFICIALLY
PERFORM NEEDLE FREE BLOOD DRAWS
AND ACTUALLY IMPROVED IV
CATHETER OUTCOMES
SIMULTANEOUSLY. IN ADDITION THE
PUBLIC STUDIES PEABO USES
CROPPING TWO AND A HALF MILLION
PERFORMED DRAWS THE MAJORITY OF
WHICH WERE CONDUCTED BY TRAIN
FULL BOTANISTS AND OTHER STATES.
HAVE BEEN ZERO ADVERSE EVENT
EVER REPORTED SUGGESTED REGIONAL
FDA CLEARANCE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. PATIENT SAFETY IS
PARAMOUNT IN THIS NEW PROCEDURE
STILL HAS NURSING A CONTROL OF
THE PATIENT'S IV CATHETER. THE
PHLEBOTOMIST WILL NEVER START
STOP OR PAUSE ANY RUNNING IV
INFUSIONS AND THEY WILL NT BE
INSERTING OR REMOVING ANY IV%
CATHETERS. AND LASTLY ALSO
BOUGHT A MISS ANDERSON IS
COMPLETE IN PERSON TRAINING AND
DEMONSTRATE COMPETENCY TO
PERFORM THE PROCEDURE SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY. IN CALIFORNIA TODAY
THE MAJORITY OF BLOOD DRAWS ARE
CONDUCTED BY PHLEBOTOMIST AND
THIS BILL WILL ENABLE THEM IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR NURSE
COLLEAGUES UTILIZED THE STATE
FOR AND MORE HUMANE. PROCEDURE
HIGHER YOU TO VOTE I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH DOCTOR ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT WE SHOULD HAVE RYAN
SPENCER THE GARAGE WHICH AVAIL
FOR QUESTIONS WITH SPENCER I'M
SORRY. ON BEHALF OF THE BECTON
DICKSON AND COMPANY A CASES FOR
KATE AND THEN HAD A WIN SO ****
AND SUPPORT AND HERE TO HELP
ANSWER QUESTIONS AS WELL. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONES. SUPPORT
FOR AB ELEVEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT. IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. OF AB
ELEVEN TWENTY. I HAVE NO ONE TO
END UP IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE MOST OF
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION-
FIRST WITNESS CURTIS LANG. FROM
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION. YES GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESPONDED CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND REGISTERED
NURSE IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE
CURRENTLY OPPOSED AB ELEVEN
TWENTY. FIRST I'M NOT STATING
THEIR PARTICIPATION ADVOCATES
YOU NAY IS NOT OPPOSED TO THAT
BASKING IN TECHNOLOGY THAT
MINIMIZES PATIENT NEEDLE STICKS
QUITE THE CONTRARY NURSES ARE
VERY COMPASSIONATE ABOUT THEIR
PATIENTS AND I'M HERE TO PROVIDE
AND WILL DO ALL THAT WE CAN TO
MINIMISE PAIN TRAUMA. AND TRAUMA
EXPERIENCED BY THE PATIENTS
HOWEVER DO OPPOSE THE USE OF
UNLICENSED AND ENACT WE TRAIN
THE BOTTOM IS TO USE THIS
TECHNOLOGY TO ACCESS PERIPHERAL
MANY FAMOUS CHARACTERS THE
PURPOSE OF WITHDRAWING BLOOD.
FROM PATIENTS RECEIVING INFUSION
THERAPY. PROCEDURES BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF AUTOMATIC AND DOES THAT
HIS- AND POSES A THREAT TO THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY. OF
HOSPITALIZED PATIENTS. THE
EDUCATE REQUIRED THE PROPER CARE
FROM THAT'S THE CARE AND MANAGE.
OF PERIPHERALLY IN. INTO
CATHETER AND OTHER STILL.
TRAININGS ASSEMBLY BALANCE.
SINCE THAT THE BOTTOM CAN SAVE
USE AND APPARATUS WITH BUT I'VE
CATHETER BUT I THINK EDUCATION
TO CARE FOR AND THEN IT CAP IN
THE SENSE REQUIRE TO DRAW BLOOD
SAFELY FROM NINETY. THE
INSERTION OF IN CTHETERS THE
POST INSERTION OF THE
INTRAVENOUS AB AND THE
MANAGEMENT OF INTRAVENOUS
INFUSIONS IS A PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF DIRECT CARE
REGISTERED NURSE CANNOT BE
DELEGATED TO UNLICENSED
PERSONNEL THE ANSWER OF AN
INTRAVENOUS CATHETER INTO A
PATIENT'S CREATES A PATHWAY
DIRECTLY INTO THE VENICE
BLOODSTREAM IT REQUIRES
EXCELLENT TECHNIQUE BOTH FOR THE
INSERTION AND PROPOSED INSERTION
MANAGEMENT OF THE CATHETER AND
THE CAP THEIR INSERTION SITE IN
ORDER TO MINIMIZE THE LIKELIHOOD
OF INFECTION OR THE INTRODUCTION
OF BACTERIA. DIRECTLY INTO THE
BLOODSTREAM THAT IS WHY IT IS
THE GOAL EVERY ARE AND IS THERE
A PROTECT EVERY PERIPHERALLY
INSERTED CATHETER IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO ADMINISTER PHYSICIAN OR
IV THERAPY INCLUDE ID MEDICATION
AND TO AVOID HAVING TO REPLACE
THE IDEA AFTER AUGMENTATION
ADDITIONAL PAIN AND DISCOMFORT
FOR THAT REASON THE MANAGEMENT
OF THE INTRAVENOUS SITE AND
ACCESS TO THE INTERCHANGEABLE TO
PHYSICIANS AND LICENSED NURSE IN
THE HIGH POPULOUS SETTING. SO
THE QUESTION IS WHY DO WE NEED
THIS LEGISLATION THANKS TO THE
ALREADY USING THIS TECHNOLOGY IN
CALIFORNIA TO MINIMIZE PATIENT
NEEDLE STICKS THANK YOU CARRILLO
MEMBERS LIKE TO DIVIDE IT PLEASE
ENTER AND CANNOT CURRENTLY USING
IT TO MINIMIZE PATIENT NEEDLES
AS WE BOTH KNOW TODAY. THANKS
VERY MUCH FOR AND NEXT UP WE
HAVE JETS AMOUNT FROM CALIFORNIA
FOR THE- ON THE PHONE AS WELL
YOU CAN YOU ARE TWO MINUTES FOR
YOUR TEST. ADULT THANK YOU I
WELCOME BERMAN. GOOD MORNING MY-
NAME IS JEFF VALLEY BUT BUT-
LABOR FOR. AND REST. BUT STRONG
UP. TO AP ELEVEN. CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION REPRESENTS TWO
POINT ONE MILLION UNION MEMBERS
INCLUDING AFFILIATES REPRESENT
BEGAN THAT OF MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS SUCH AS NURSES
PHLEBOTOMIST AND DOCTORS. THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE IS IMPLICATED
BY THE FILM. REGRETTABLY WE ARE
IN THE POSITION OF HAVING TO
OPPOSE THE LATEST ITERATION OF
THE BILL WHICH HAS BEEN BROUGHT
TO THE LEGISLATURE BY SINGLE
HEALTHCARE DEVICE MANUFACTURER.
VILLADA VASCULAR WHOSE SOLE AIM
IS TO GET PEOPLE DEVICE AND TO
AS MANY CLINICAL CARE SETTING
OFF BOMBS. ASSEMBLY WE THINK
THIS IS AN UNNECESSARY CHANGE
TWIN NURSES OF PRACTICE. SOLELY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF SELLING MORE
DEVICES AND MAXIMIZING PROFIT.
RIGHT NOW NURSES ALREADY CAN AND
DO USE PEOPLE DEVICES SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY IN CALIFORNIA. THE
SPONSORS HAVE NEVER DENIED THAT.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE PEOPLE
DEVICES ONLY A COUPLE OF YEARS
VENOUS CATHETER WHICH FOR GOOD
REASON BELONGS WITH THE NURSES
PERFUME. A LOT OF VASCULAR JUST
TO CHANGE THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
TO ALLOW UNLICENSED THE BOTTOM
IS TO ACCESS UNITS CAPTURED. WE
SLIGHTLY SPONSORS THAT THAT THEY
HAVE NOT SOLVED FOR OUR CONCERN
ABOUT LICENSURE IMPLICATIONS.
WERE ONLY ALERTED FOR THE BILL
LAST WEEK AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
FEDERATION AND OUR AFFILIATES
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR ON FILE. AS A
PHLEBOTOMIST WITH UNLICENSED IF
YOU SAYS THAT PEOPLE DIVIDE THE
LICENSE APPLICATIONS TRACK WITH
A HIGHER TIER LICENSE
PROFESSIONAL WHETHER THAT BE A
NURSE A LAB SCIENTIST OR DOCTOR
. THE I'M SIX TRY TO SOLVE THIS
BIKE A TO. ROLE FOR THE LICENSE
. THAT CREATES ADDITIONAL WORK
ON ALREADY STRESSED AND
OVERWORKED MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS. ARE FOR THESE
REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR NO VOTE ON AB ELEVEN TWENTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANNOUNCER ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WANT TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ELEVEN TWENTY.
ANY WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM WHO WANT TO ADD ON IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN TWENTY
SEEING NONE. WE ARE THE
TELEPHONE LINES IS ANYONE
CALLING IN WHO JUST WANT TO ADD
ON WRITING YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH IF ANY-
AND OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. WE
DO HAVE FOUR PEOPLE QUEUING UP
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE NUMBER
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JACKIE GRAY ALL HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE U. F. C. W. WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL THE TEAMSTERS AND
ENGINEERS AND- ENGINEERS AND
SCIENTISTS THE CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. ACTUAL LINE FORTY FOUR ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RAND MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
THE AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
THE STATE'S LARGEST NONPROFIT
PROVIDER OF DIRECT MEDICAL CARE
TO PEOPLE WITH AIDS I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NATIONAL
LINE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS
PAT WHALEN ELSE WILL SNAP YOU
SEE HERE ON BEHALF OF UNITED
NURSES ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
UNIONS OF HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS I JOIN IN THE
COMMENTS OF CNA IN MY PREPARED
AND- DROP IN SESSION. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO QUEUE UP IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO WILL GO TO WIND THIRTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STOPS MY NAME IS TO STOP MAYOR
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE.
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB ELEVEN
TWENTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HEALTH CARE. ACTUAL EACH SHAPE
UP. AND NEXT WILL LINE NUMBER.
FORTY FIVE PLEASE WAIT. HI I'M
OPPOSING ON THE OF ALL THE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO
WITH THAT LET'S BRING BACK A
COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS DO WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND FAMILY I
BELIEVE- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MR GRAYSON. THANK YOU CHAIR
BERMAN AND- OF. REASON MY PART I
HAVE SEVERAL QUESTIONS OF PLEASE
IF I MAY THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE
FOR OUR- AND I HAD TO STEP OUT
DURING A PRESENTATION- IT WAS
PRESENTING IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE.
ARE PHLEBOTOMIST- ARE THEY
LICENSED THERE BECAUSE WHAT I
HEAR- UNLICENSED PHLEBOTOMIST
SO- DO WE HAVE. OUR FULL BOTTOM
IS LICENSE AND WHAT IS THE
SCOPE. OF THAT LICENSURE IN
REFERENCE TO A BLOOD DRAW USING
THIS PARTICULAR DEVICE NO I'M
GONNA HAVE- START WITH DOCTOR
DAD GONE IF HE WANTS TO ADDRESS.
THIS QUESTION. BYLER THANK YOU
SO IN A NUMBER AND IS NOT YOUR
YOU W. SO- INTEL. THEY ARE
FORCED ON THE THAT EITHER HAVE
A- REQUIRED FOR FOOTBALL. OR
IT'S SORT OF. WHICH OPERATING
SAID TO LICENSE CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THEM. SO YES THEY ARE
THEY ARE CERTIFIED THEY HAVE A
SCOPE AND THEY HAVE TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS- AND THAT THAT
WOULD CALIFORNIA'S. SO THE THAT
TRAINING AND THIS MAY BE TOWARD
THE DOCTOR AS WELL. AS THAT
TREATING- RESULT AND- THAT IS
SPECIFIC TO THIS DEVICE A BLOOD
DRAW DOES THAT TRAINING RESULT
IN CERTIFICATION. ON TOP OF THE
LICENSE SINCE IT THIS IS A
TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS COME AFTER.
THEY MOST LIKELY WERE LICENSED
THAT- ALL START AND THEN LET ME-
DOCTORED TO HAVE GONE FINISH
THAT THE TRAINEES SO IF THE
HOSPITAL WANTS TO UTILIZE THIS
TECHNOLOGY. THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT WILL DO THE TRAINING FOR
THE TECHNOLOGY AND I KNOW YOU'RE
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT LIABILITY
LIABILITY WOULD BE ON THE
PHLEBOTOMIST AND THE HOSPITAL IF
THEY DID NOT. PROVIDE ADEQUATE
TRAINING. AND BY ALL I ALSO WANT
TO. REITERATE THAT SAYS YES THIS
IS A NEW DEVICE BUT IT'S BEEN.
TWO AND A HALF MILLION TIMES.
AND OVER HALF OF THOSE TIMES IT
WAS BY A PHLEBOTOMIST. SO DR DEF
CON I'M NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE
MORE TO ADD TO THAT. WELL I'M
NOT REALLY OF THE SOME OF THE
CAPITAL BOTANIST LEARN IS. OF
THEIR CERTIFICATION IS DONE AND
BY IN FULL BOTTOM ME SCHOOL ARE
CONTROLLED BY THE STATE. AND
SOME OF IT IS ACTED ON BY THE
HOSPITAL FACILITIES IN THE
CURRENT WAY THE STATUTES ARE
WRITTEN. AND SO IT'S BOTH IT'S
KIND OF SPLIT DEPENDING ON WHAT
YOU HAVE TO LEARNING SO IT'S
VERY COMMON FOR A LOT OF US TO
HAVE ON THE JOB TRAINING. IN
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL TODAY. SO
AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN YOU
ANSWERED- PART OF. PART OF MY
QUESTION MY NEXT QUESTION WAS
ABOUT THE LIABILITY BECAUSE-
THERE ARE LICENSURE
IMPLICATIONS. AND IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S NOT A
DOCTOR OR A NURSE THAT'S
RETURNING WHETHER PHLEBOTOMIST
ISSUES IT'S REALLY. AN
ADMINISTRATOR OF A HOSPITAL THAT
DETERMINES. AND SO AGAIN GOING
BACK TO THE LICENSOR
IMPLICATIONS WHAT. ARE THE
IMPLICATIONS FOR LICENSURE IF
THERE IS SOMETHING THAT GOES
AWRY. SO DOCTORS HAVE GONE DO
YOU MIND ANSWERING THAT. SURE OF
COURSE BOB SO FULL BOTTOM IS
WORK FOR THE LABORATORY IN THE
HOSPITAL MAY WORK UNDER THE
DIRECT SUPERVISION OF THE
MEDICAL DIRECTOR WITH THE
POSITION OF THE LABORATORY OF
THE HOSPITAL. SO THAT THAT WOULD
BE THE PERSON ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FIRST. OVERSEEING
THEM THE SUPERVISING THEM. SO
THEN IF A NURSE OR A DOCTOR IS
PRESENT AND AVAILABLE WHAT WOULD
BE THE BENEFIT FOR THE ADVANTAGE
OF USING A PHLEBOTOMIST OVER A
NURSE OR A DOCTOR. THERE IS NOT
NECESSARILY A BENEFIT IN IN
GENERAL IN LARGE HOSPITALS A
NURSES ARE NOT DOING THE BLOOD
DRAWS SO IF THERE IS A NURSE OR
A DOCTOR AVAILABLE NURSES ARE
ALREADY ALLOWED TO USE THESE
DEVICES. IT BUT IN BIG HOSPITALS
NURSES ARE NOT. YOU KNOW THEY'RE
VERY THEY'RE WORKING VERY HARD
AND THEY DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
TIME TO DRAW BLOOD AND THAT'S
ONE OF THE BOTTOM IS JUST CALL
THEM. THANK YOU. THE USER OF AYE
SIR FOR THANK YOU THAT CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD- I'M- AND ACTUALLY KIND
OF IN LINE WITH US IMMIGRATION
COMMENTS I THINK ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF ALLOWING
PHLEBOTOMIST TO DO THIS. IS WE
HAVE STAFFING ISSUES RIGHT NOW.
WE ALL TALKED ABOUT CODE AND
WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR IN OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. NOTHING IS
AGAINST NURSES I MEAN WOULD LOVE
NURSES TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS BUT
SOMETIMES ARE JUST NOT ENOUGH OF
THEM SO TO BE ABLE TO DO. IN MY
OPINION AND IN SERVICE TRAINING.
TO TEACH A FULL BOTTOM IS HOW TO
USE A NEW TECHNOLOGY IS NOT A
BAD WAY TO GO EXPECTS THE IN THE
IN THE CLIMATE THAT WE'RE IN
RIGHT NOW SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. THE
MEASURE MEASURE AND I. BELIEVE
THAT SOMEONE REALLY. THANK YOU
MISTER THEY GIVE US CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO THE AUTHOR FOR BRING
THIS BILL FOR I UNDERSTAND
OBVIOUSLY WANT TO PUT THE
COMFORT OF THE PATIENT IT'S
PARAMOUNT- YOU KNOW CERTAINLY
WANTS ONLINE HOSPITAL BED BEING
POKED WITH MORE MORE NEEDLES IS
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE. BUT I COME
FROM A NURSE FAMILY AND I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THE HESITANCY
ABOUT ALLOWING MORE PEOPLE INTO
THE- IV STREAM OF FORTUNATELY AS
YOU ENCOURAGE ME TALK TO MY MOM
SHE ACTUALLY DOES DO BLOOD DRAWS
A LARGE HOSPITAL SETTING AND
THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN THEIR
STANDARD PRACTICE AND I
UNDERSTAND. THE HESITANCY TO
ALLOW ANOTHER PERSON INTO THE IV
STREAM SO WHILE THIS BILL I
THINK IS LAUDABLE I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY TOTALLY
UNDERSTANDING WORLD OF CONCERNS
ARE AND MAKING SURE THAT PATIENT
SAFETY IS AT THE CORE OF THIS.
SO I JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW
THAT- I APPRECIATIVE EFFORT BUT
I WILL BE ABLE SUPPORT- YOU
MISTER LEE AND I. THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO HAVE- DISCUSSIONS AHEAD
OF TIME ON THIS. THE ISN'T
REALLY ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES ON
THE- ON THE COMMITTEE SAYING
NONE. A MOVIE BACK- MISSOURI
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
SUMMER IN THE ELECTRICALS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
AND I REALLY WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO TOOK THE TIME TO
WORK WITH WITH ME AND THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL. AND I
RECOGNIZE THAT SOME CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN RAISED ABOUT VARIOUS
ISSUES MOST IMPORTANTLY ABOUT
PATIENT SAFETY. LOOKING AT THE
PARLIAMENT'S MADE IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND AGREED TO BY THE
AUTHOR SUCH AS THE ABILITY FOR
NURSES TO LIMIT A PHLEBOTOMIST
FROM ACCESSING THE IV. I'M
COMFORTABLE MOVING THE BILL FOR
TODAY HOWEVER I REALLY WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
ENSURE THERE'S NO MORE ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT- ANY ADDITIONAL
DETAILS MAY EMERGE AS THE BILL
MOVES ALONG- AND FOR THEIR
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAD. WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY PLEASE CALL VOTE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN HI. BERMAN
HI FLORA. FLORA HI BLOOM. BLOOM
I BONTA. BONTA NOT VOTING WHEN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES
DAVIES HI FONG. FONG HI GIPSON
GIPSON GRAYSON RECENT HI IRWIN
FIVE BERMAN HIGHLY. WE NOT
VOTING MCCARTY. MEDINA MEDINA
NOT VOTING MULLIN MULLIN HI TEN
. TEN HI WEBER. WEBER NOT VOTING. THE BILL HAS TOLD US THAT BILL
THAT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU- AND THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS LAST UP WE
HAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR. GOT
GOT MULTIPLE MOVES AND A COUPLE
SECONDS. I WANT TO URGE ANYBODY
WHO ISN'T HERE YET TO COME DOWN
TO FORTY TWO OR TWO. THAT ON IF
YOU MISS ROADS- SO- WITH THAT-
PLEASE CALL VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CONSENT CALENDAR AB
FOURTEEN NINETY EIGHT LOW
MOTIONS DO PASTOR PREPARATIONS
BERMAN HI BERMAN HI FLORA. FLORA
HI BLOOM. BLOOM I BONTA. BONTA
AYE WHEN I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE DAVIES DAVIS III FONG FONG
AYE GIPSON ALL RIGHT GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON AYE IRWIN.
FIVE IRWIN HI WE ARE MCCARTY.
MANY MEDINA AYE MULLIN. MULLIN.
TEN TEN AYE WEBER. NUMBER NINE
THAT'S OUT- AND I WAS REMISS IN
NOT EARLIER THINKING DAVID AND A
MEMBERS AND FOR SITTING IN TODAY
- ABSENT COLLEAGUES FR THAT
THEY SO MUCH- AND WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OF FOR. HOPEFULLY JUST
FIVE MINUTES FOR ANY ABSENT
COLLEAGUES TO COME IN AND OUT ON
IF THEY MISS ROADS- PERFECT.
YOUR FIRST YEAR OF. THIS ON OVER
TO WE'RE GONNA OPEN THINGS BACK
UP THANK YOU THIS. YOU WERE
MISSING- BECAUSE ONCE AGAIN. YOU
ALWAYS WANT TO. WITHDRAWAL
COMING AND YEAH AND THAT TURNED
INTO YEAH YEAH. AB SIX SEVEN
SIX. HI GRAYSON GRAYSON I
MCCARTY. TEN I EIGHTY SIX SEVEN
SIX. THANK USUALLY. FROM THE-
POINT. YEAH AND THEN I CAN OR
NOT. TWO FOUR. YOU WANT NINE
WELL I MEAN IT WOULDN'T POSSIBLY
WITH THE- OR- ONE REVIEW WALK
WITHIN ABOUT FORTY OKAY HI FIVE
HUNDRED AND CHECK THAT OUT
THANKS THAT'S SOMETHING BUT OKAY
THAT'LL PERFECT WE GOT TO HAVE
pYOURS RIGHT. I. FOR HOW LONG YOU. AB TWO NINE FOUR MCCARTY
MCCARTY. SB SIX SEVEN SIX ARE. I
AB ELEVEN TWENTY MCCARTY. TWENTY
NINE AND COMES FOUNDRY BEFORE TO
EIGHT MCCARTY. THERE IS. THERE
WITH ARMENIANS.